hi I'm Julia and I'm going to be on a
panel debate about female genital
mutilation it's a really complex issue
it's a human rights cause and the
YouTube community voted for me to go to
devils to have this debate the debate
will be facilitated by Nick Kristof who
is an award-winning journalist for The
New York Times as well as other experts
and leaders on the panel and what we
want is for the community to pose the
questions so please go to youtube.com
forward slash Davos and either video or
text in your questions also favorite the
ones that you like the best we'll be
picking the favorite questions and be
putting them to the panel so please
submit a question now the deadline is
Saturday the thirtieth of January and we
really look forward to answering them
live at Davos
you